citizens of the reject Nation it is time
once again to dive into the DC Animated
Universe for a part dude Electric
Boogaloo very excited about we're diving
into the long Halloween you have read
but haven't seen once upon a time it's
been years years another era another
time another world we are gonna be
watching part two today I'm very excited
to dive in because I rather enjoyed part
one please do leave a comment below let
us know what you would like us to dive
into next because you may have noticed
we are done with the dcamu and you've
probably even seen us rank it by now
whenever in chronology life is but in
the meantime hit that like hit that
comment bar hit lots of buttons and
share this with your friends and family
so we know you like it and if you want
to watch this in its entirety front to
back beginning to end with our resting
faces
become a patron because those super sexy
rejects get to see every last morsel of
this enjoyment alright without further
Ado let's get into the long Halloween
part dude
and that first one was great I know
right
dates are falling off calendar man's
wall yeah go talk to your boy
and hey Josh dumel's holding it down too
truly truly rip Naya Rivera also holding
it down
just love revisiting these comic panels
yeah like the art in this book is great
rest in peace to the great Tim sale the
artist on this book didn't that just
happen within the last like three years
yeah reason
[Music]
let's do this thing so excited
tell me this never has to end oh all
things wither Bruce but if we're lucky
not for a long time that is gorgeous
oh
aren't you forgetting something
[Music]
my pen again
oh
it's the pies and
that's a great place to end and start a
part one part two very clever okay
[Music]
I can't resist you literally that's the
point bat brain no man can dude
now disappear like Homer into the bush
stupid sexy Homer
[Music]
oh good
I love the establishing shots just as
discussed not the sexiest holiday not
the sexiest holidays now
Gordon has one of the Alzheimer
mustaches truly up there with Sam
Elliott doing the work are we going to
Paddy's Day next oh we are
hmm
leprechaun 8 in Gotham the foundation
was such a burden to you just like the
rest of the company
at Alfred too yeah
[Music]
let's go
again the timsail lighting is gorgeous
yeah even though her suit is totally
different it still feels like a 10 sale
drawing
before
[Music]
come out
whip it good
I just love how he always returns to
that same like syndicated smile
[Music]
oh bad
she's controlling you somehow come on
sorry yeah slice off his Vine
oh he is
[Music]
oh come on cats
cat's natural predator poison ivy yeah I
was like how many of these plants are
cat toxic
ideas are apparently cat toxic cat
owners read Christmas is lethal to cats
how did you know appearing with Ivy in
public and signing assets over to the
Roman I'll wake the lawyers sir
Alfred I think I'd like to go home why
we can yeah yeah okay no communicate
she's gonna leave you man this woman is
clearly depressed
oh you're right bro foolishness is this
Chong's been supplying holiday with his
guns you should have listened to me Jim
moved on this guy sooner we might have
learned something holiday likes a Luger
the holiday killer is covering his
tracks Mother's Day this one snuck up on
us yeah I was April fools a minute ago
[Laughter]
God the establishing shots are just like
gorgeous every frame of painting boy
what a cool Arkham
let's go
my man my other man I think Sullivan T's
in the first one you're you're no shame
to Grundy he's always he's always tops
you know me
let's go
oh brutal
whoa
you can do this whoa
Batman evil dead I love how they zoomed
in in the digital art to artifact it
is
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
jeez
dude that was awesome gorgeous and I
love how like they they made the line
work all like rough yeah that digital
artifacts inside my yeah I love that his
world is extra edgy like more textured
more grimy
classic bat face
[Music]
Papa
oh no
[Music]
I love the lighting
couldn't save them
just a kid is he okay I don't
let's go jeez Gotham
Freud's having a field there mother I
want to be in the room rumor it happened
the room where it happened we had a
chance with Wayne but now that he's out
we have to restructure that is exactly
why you need me I do not
if I bring you in now our new earners
will think I am lining up a successor
and that will make me look old and weak
can't have that
end of discussion now go buy something
the address a car I don't care just make
sure everybody sees it
make sure the family looks financially
soluble stay stable whatever the word is
the night Alberto Falcone was murdered
you were the only passenger on that
yacht who didn't give us a statement
except that it would have been a matter
of public record and could place my name
next to that of a young lady I went to
meet I don't think her husband likes me
very much that's very convenient no not
for her husband
[Laughter]
hahaha
sure nice Gordon yes my father built
hospitals with Falcone but the only
influence he was under was an
overwhelming desire to save innocent
lives and how many other innocent lives
did he end up trading for it too
that I know of oh oh five bullet wounds
to the chest your son needs to be in a
hospital no where Luigi Maroni could
find him and finish the job no Carmine
is my only son Alfred get my bag right
away sir thank you shades of this in the
Batman and they have the voice over and
they have the dates like there's a lot
of long Halloween influence in the
Batman
you shouldn't be here your pop saved my
life guess that makes us family it fell
out of your pocket sometimes all it
takes to get out of a bad situation is a
good flip of the coin it didn't work for
you tonight still two heads are better
than one
[Music]
leave nothing to chance my father was
dead buy a mobster's hand within a year
any connection between my family and the
Roman died then too thank you for
stopping by now get the hell out win or
lose the only thing that ends war is
peace
I don't know I don't I'm Snogging his
daughter pops oh boy
uh Father's Day damn
[Music]
God who's under there
oh yeah
so I heard a gunshot are you okay
I left the gun damn when was there time
to do that yeah when did he run up to
him was it when he lost him he ran back
really quick
I got a picture to maintain yeah oh no
it's me Father's Day needs the gun in it
strange place to do business guessing
it's the last spot the pigs leave you
alone these days
hmm
[Music]
grieved
waking late working late oh nice
[Music]
I'm here to make peace with the law you
want Falcone and I got plenty on him in
exchange for dropping all outstanding
warrants against me and my men heads
I'll take it ugh
yup I would love if in this continuity
he became Two Face just by spilling that
coffee like
olds
oh I tell you harv if I could I'd have
every cop in the city here tonight but
they're all taking the night off the
Independence Day and all you know
scarecrow see you on the other side whoa
foreign
I've been thinking about it and maybe
you're right
oh Kevin kids
let's conceive right here
oh
damn
Harvey no
Harvey you have so many splinters yeah
that's how you become two-faced yep
[Music]
got this guy come on
not till I know why this scumbag is
trying to kill me if I was trying to
kill you
ready oh no
oh
whoa
someone's trying to provoke you Dent
into doing what good question
ow damn it man
[Music]
oh okay
oh God even animated it still hurts yeah
crunchy if seven Maids with seven mobs
swept it for half a year no
delivering him wasn't part of the deal
so we can do whatever we want with him
what fun
is that Ray Winstone Twinkle Twinkle
Little Bat oh it could be right
your business with the Roman Inns
tonight nope
yeah whoa
oh cool
[Music]
whoa
oh interesting what oh that's right
no
down here what do you got oh
it's the beginning of a mind fracture
you left the basement door open again
turn the basement today
[Music]
that must be a Luger Mr moroney you have
confessed to 19 counts
your captain
hook the roof the roof is here waiting
for you
where'd you find them you don't want to
know
felony is under direct order
from Carmine the Roman Falcone felonies
nah you guys are Saint
no wonder Gotham is the way it is people
love Mobsters here laughing at you know
Murder like give it to him ah throw them
in the river
I got it
what is it Hopper happy to share in
light of the witnesses cross
I need to request a continuance uh what
is that like a holiday what
you know like Father's Day Luigi Maroney
sends his regards oh no of course oh no
damn it
damn it I pissed that out so well
oh man
I forgot all about that they played it
well because it's like the origin yeah
yeah they think it's you
are you
do you know who I am
you you sound tired why not let me take
the wheel I'm sorry no one told you harv
you're dead oh oh yeah
I know it's the perfect time the doctor
says he'll be fine in a few days oh my
God Define fun he's gone see he's fine
he's fine now I know you're a liar a
murderer a father
oh Jesus a coward goodbye Dent sure
fine he wants to talk to you
yeah
yep
ow your next Inspector Gadget
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
my God no
oh oh oh he's being sucked I thought
there was like a boat looming I mean
that's also bad but like pretty bad last
bad I was like terrifying
happy birthday happy Italian birthday to
you and my beautiful sister Carla where
is she Carla oh she's on her way
[Music]
yeah
where's rat catcher dinner time already
oh buddy
born on a Monday
Tuesday married on a Wednesday
Thursday a horse on Friday night on
Saturday
very down Sunday
Friday I'm in Love
[Music]
my new name will be Monday
if the pattern holds I believe you have
something holiday wants
this is the longest goddamn prisoner
tarantula I've ever seen I guess you
guys just can't get enough of me yeah
there's one way to put it
the blend of all the gothams in this is
so cool
[Music]
my dude getting a little action yeah
sequence
[Applause]
oh yeah
yup yup yup
oh
[Music]
wrong one grab him dent
if you're alive he's no longer ruining
this operation
relax Jim I'm not here to kill Moroni
I'm here to thank him for giving me a
new
outlook oh yeah your gun that's coming
in oh if I know it was meant for Harvey
but possession is
uh-huh if you're not Harvey then who are
you holiday we found the guns in your
basement you found the guns
of course huh of course I think Thomas
Wayne was on to something you can't beat
him Jimbo not your way join them first
oh boy
other heads you also died
no get back in there Grundy you and I
know that both sides of that corner
house
nice
I suppose this little trap was your idea
drop the gun now
[Music]
whoa oh geez boy
make sure that gun gets down there
ah
[Music]
come on you need their help a little bit
talk to my boy that way he's helping you
out you know what today is It's All
Hallows Eve the 31st day of the tenth
month and the 305th of this
miserable leap year the best day of all
and taco Tuesday
yes
yes oh those look great give me a taco
Tuesday holiday kill
um
[Music]
oh
there's a guy Retreat yeah do you know
what my people call this past year the
long Halloween
title there it is part one and two we're
in two now we leave the wives out of it
whose wives I guess Justice really is
blind let's just
[Music]
are you going to tell me why you're so
obsessed with them
oh
oh I never thanked you for finding me
and getting me home that night you
thought I was your mother
let's go Crow's fear toxin it's a good
excuse I don't even know my mother's
name but I think there's someone who can
tell me uh-oh your father
oh damn is there even such a thing as a
normal family in this city maybe not for
people like us
[Music]
oh
nice delay too with the sounds quality
I forgot to use that too for the Batman
with the whole right Catwoman it's a
great long Halloween stuff in the Batman
we talked last week about the Dark
Knight and the Batman are both very yeah
pieces of this
oh my God
I'll Scarecrow on a horse too little
Batman beginsie yeah I was gonna say is
that just this ark or does he ride
horses a lot it does sometimes but it's
very much that like long Halloween
inspired so much sure like look at this
[Music]
everyone's invited to this party oh yes
everyone oh no the counter man I gotta
invite no that's messed up everyone but
the holiday
[Music]
oh
let's go
yeah you're the Falcone I like Sophia
hey there he is gang's all here
[Music]
yes
dual wielding not bad
this love is revolvers
everybody's got their own unique gun
right
no
just that window yeah
oh just pulls the trigger wow
get your F-bomb it really isn't up to me
good luck
hello damn oh
[Applause]
wow nice oh
no oh let's see Catwoman's nightmares
though do you want to see that
is Glover's whole hand he just took his
hand off
oh a fear toxin fueled oh no yeah that's
probably for the best fear toxin Grundy
on guard you sanctimonious
[Applause]
what happens
[Music]
all my calls I have to terminate someone
a joke break
oh my God
[Music]
you could do so much good for this city
poison ivy
[Music]
whoa
did to Dove man
now let's get you out of all this
as good as she can telepathically catch
herself
Harvey
you don't have to do this
no no oh
perform the same surgery your daddy did
[Music]
oh geez
oh what what do we got
oh no no
[Music]
no no no no no no
damn it
[Music]
oh
ah she's got Lethal Weapon sure
how's that
is that her mom the Roman is dead and
Two-Face killed him the long Halloween
is over we'll get you help
betterhelp.com the promise we made right
here to take down the Roman in the end
was it worth it he's asking if the good
guys won
but we won't know for a very long time
if it was worth it I love that two
angles like the the big wide on the
two-faced side and a close-up for dent
yeah so many great visual choices
gilva
no it had to be done you know that the
same way you knew Harvey never went to
Oxford damn it that was me what the end
Alberto Falcone what if you could see
how in love we were then it was both of
them I was pregnant he was heir to the
Roman Empire and his father could never
welcome into the family A Child
conceived out of wedlock of course our
marriage was annulled and our child
ripped from my womb no you wanted
Revenge I wanted Justice
no Harvey and I were so much alike only
what was inside him hadn't yet been
ripped out the baby never pacifier
but Harvey
in the end
I loved him
not the crispy half
I need to know that holiday is done not
done finished
semantics great lot damn oh why did you
tell me I was really enjoying especially
this movie with the like oh it's going
to take a lot more good people trying to
make things better before we see real
change before we see real trick or treat
oh change is happening Bruce oh
Dick Grayson come for candy when you're
wrong
[Music]
oh
precious the scariest costume
the family from the alley
man that was good
how lovely
oh man
what a movie yeah man jeez John DiMaggio
was Mad Hatter okay he's not all right
Ray I feel like 80 Seconds poison ivy oh
fun that's cool I feel like this has
happened to us once before with
I don't know if it was a Mad Hatter
appearance but it was somebody who
sounded like Ray wins
away well he's got that that unique you
know Gravelly bridge
if you're mad at something it's probably
Ray Winstone yeah it's funny and then
you're in a cast too where you've got
like one guy doing a spot on Mark Hamill
yeah
is pretty close to him
yeah man oh God what a song this is like
it makes me want to go back and reread
the comic because like again from my
patchy recollection it seems like this
did a nice job of kind of being faithful
and at least communicating the I
remember the experience being very like
there's a lot of air in between yeah it
breathes it breathes and it Broods and
it's very moody and and you feel the
length of that year and I thought this
did a really nice job across these two
installments of really yeah making you
feel the the breadth of that year and
then you know I don't know when these
came out in relation to each other when
they were released but you know at least
for us watching here you know even just
like a week was a week apart yeah it
feels like we just yeah went on some
kind of year-long you know uh and the
opening so paste and ponderous that you
still feel the weight of like they can't
solve it I love that we talked about it
in the first one like that frustration
of like this is still happening we we
can't do and then they they did such a
good job with when they put the Gap in
there with Bruce being taken over and
then the comeback with like those months
that passed like it's so well paced yeah
yeah I think
the second one is like
this is probably four and a half stars
for me uh I think this will be in the
top like top five of the of the DCA like
any of them this was successful part two
in particular part two in particular
like they're both three will be ranked
separately yeah I got two okay that's
how I rank uh part one's like a four and
it's like oh two one to one oh this is
recent reason 2021 just yeah yeah I seem
to recall this
um
oh
it's for you sir
oh that's so good well how are you guys
that's so good there's a Justice League
there's a job
that's interesting what a fun button
that ties to probably nothing were there
allusions to the Justice League nope
Batman World unless like this starts a
new universe of animated films like the
tomorrow versus whatever that's very fun
that was half but half of my brain is
like we've been here for a year dealing
with this okay
CSI investigator Barry [__] flash you
could
you're a better shot than holiday what
are you doing
um but yeah this was um
first one's like a solid four star
because I love the style I love the
pacing I love like the way it feels so
cinematic but it's something about the
second one that really like I got very
emotional with uh with her reveal
um and I I remembered that from the
comic there were things that I had
forgotten it's been it's been a few
years since I've read it and like there
were a couple twists and turns that I I
didn't remember if I misremembered like
I didn't remember if I assumed the
Selena Kyle twist was in it because of
the Batman or if it was so I was like 80
but there were a couple moments I was
like am I misremembering or is it that
accurate but the I knew the Twist and it
was so fun to like see you
go like I know Oxford's important but
why like it was fun to feel the twist
not like land
um and and they did such a good job with
the delivery of her like I'm broken
here's everything this is why she like
they deserve to die and I hope they burn
in hell yeah no I felt so much for and
actually I really like the
characterization across this because
thinking back I'm like okay so you know
there are lots of Clues then that you
could probably piece together
um but I just really like the way that
they drew her story amid all this
because there is so much going on you
got so much batmaning and and just like
fighting and chasing crime and you know
mystery solving to do and she's always
getting shoved off to one side and like
the demeanor with which they present her
really compliments and suits that just
Dynamic of the story really well so she
does become very unassuming and by the
end that's the thing is we I think it
was fortunate that we watched hush
before this because hush
changes the twist right it does and
isn't isn't the Comic version that it's
his buddy it's just like his friend and
they set it up in the animated you're
like oh a mislead but the whole time I
was like I hadn't read it since it came
out so that would have been you know 15
years ago so I was like I just felt
under like I felt I was like but I
thought it was that and that would have
been better and then I was like it was
that but I didn't know for sure so I was
misremembering to the point where I was
like I know it's not the Riddler but I
thought it was it was homeboy yeah so
like this delivered on what that mystery
unraveling does yeah like I I don't know
this was so exceptional like this is the
world's greatest detective this is him
not being able to solve a thing and this
is like such a good reason for villainy
it's got all the greatest hits
characters but it doesn't feel bloated
yeah it's very contained to Gotham which
I love when Batman can be that's why I
love that James Gunn is keeping the
Batman to itself his stories like this
like we both like you know we were happy
to see flashing green arrow but
obviously it undermines the whole thing
that only works as a person at the end
of the end of of there's no more and
that would work in live action yeah if
we saw that in live action be like wait
no it would because there's different
mediums for different reasons but like
the Batman when he can be himself I love
Batman stories so that's why I'm excited
we're getting to Batman's maybe one of
them's gin snackles I would love that
like I I really loved his turn as red
hood and I thought here he did a great
job with both Bruce and Batman and he's
got like the perf he's he's a great uh
he's like fortuitous pick because he's
got the natural voice but I could also
absolutely see him in the suit live
action I would love if that would ever
happen
um but but yeah like the idea like
having that experience from hush I think
helped to dilute this for me because
then I was going like okay wait a minute
you know you start to think of fragments
and you're like well it could be this
but maybe I'm getting lost and maybe
they're gonna change it and there was a
moment where I was like are they just
gonna make it two-faced or something I
don't remember it being two-faced that's
the fun thing about the comic is they
they throw it pretty heavily that like
what if what if and like they did a good
job here making you consider it well and
there's I remember in the comic thinking
okay like you know okay Alberto's got to
be and then they kill him and I was like
oh damn no it's not him and and then to
bring it back around that it is the both
of them so like at a certain point he
was involved with this
um or at least that's how I took it as
this is that like we are holiday I mean
like our motivation is tied together but
I also took it as like they're both you
know shooting people oh I never I never
got I never took it that way so it's
just so it's more she's basically saying
like you know he's to blame we are
holiday because he is a big part of the
motivation for this but I am the hand
that's right that's that was the I mean
it could be it's interpretive I think uh
but yeah I think this is I mean the long
Halloween we kept talking about how
influenced the Dark Knight how
influenced the Batman how influenced all
these things there's a reason this is
the Batman story uh if you dear viewer
have not read the long Halloween I would
recommend it highly yeah uh because the
art is just as stunning as this and it's
and it's fun because it's like different
takes on the characters like it's a
Catwoman suit I've never seen before
since uh there's like the Joker the way
Tim sale illustrates them there's so
much of that and then Jeff Loeb who
ironically uh was TVs Kevin feige on the
Marvel side for a while is the writer
yeah uh Jeff Loeb like ran you know like
The Runaways and and Agents of Shield
and he was responsible for getting uh
Daredevil and the Netflix stuff greenlit
oh he ran Agents of Shield yeah this is
the Marvels the Marvel Marvel like Jeff
loeb's Marvel was all the TV stuff ah so
like from Agents of Shield through the
the Netflix Defenders that's all Jeff
Loeb he was the Kevin feige a TV but he
also wrote one of the best Batman
stories ever Chef Love's a genius writer
but I feel like like a lot of people
don't give credit to the guy that also
like the long Halloween's the comment is
one of the most yeah I feel like I've
seen his name on a few of them oh he did
uh iconic the the art style him and
himself work together a lot so like the
Hulk gray Daredevil yellow Spider-Man
blue long Halloween like that's all Jeff
Loeb who also went over to Marvel and
made some great TV so I just want to
give him his flowers because this is one
of the Batman stories absolutely one too
I mean I love how this is like a perfect
split between you have this very
involved story about the mob these very
grounded stakes and circumstances stuff
that ties in obviously to the past with
Thomas Wayne and everything but then you
also have a fully fledged you know comic
book Gotham Rogues Gallery all the
villains are and I love to anytime the
villains are like we want to figure this
out too we'd also like to knock you down
what's going on here people are just
dying and uh and yeah like going to see
calendar man and things like that and
the Darkness the pacifier silencer man
the kid and that works two-fold because
she and Harvey want to have kids yeah
she lost a kid with Alberto Falcon and
all the darkness of her saying like you
know I can't like that's so like heavy
when you know the twist yeah it's it's
brutal I I want to like this this one
they they're all the good ones compel
you to go back but this one especially
I'm like man I would love to go back and
watch this I was saying this might be my
new Halloween movie like this is a
really cool like sit down Halloween have
a four hour like let's strap in oh yeah
there's so much great uh art and so much
mood and uh yeah just like a lot of
clever twists and turns and even though
you're doing a bunch of holidays it does
feel kind of horrific Halloween stuff
you get a good amount of yeah a good
amount of Solomon Grundy in there so
that's you know in the Scarecrow like
you have your Macabre villains and your
Macabre set pieces and stuff and uh and
two I mean even the way that they do the
requisite things like oh you go back to
Crime Alley for a minute but like that
even though that's a little different
nicely yeah hewn and and yeah like
unique to this portrayal and that
scarecrow sequence great head yeah and
the different uh take on the anime like
the animation changes and bringing the
animation yeah I didn't want to
interrupt it because it was such a
powerful emotional moment but bringing
the animation of his nightmare to Joe
Chill killing and he was a different
animation style yeah oh good catch he
was the Nightmare and then the animation
of the family was different and then it
was like more clean yeah so cool yeah
that's like a literal visual
representation yeah nightmare the
nightmare touching the the dream reality
it's so good like this was this is
amongst the top for me this was really
spectacular and the trio of Gordon and
and Batman and Dent is so much fun to
watch great Alfred moments across this
too which you always want oh yeah short
of somehow shoehorning Nightwing I think
this is everything we want in the Batman
yes and Nightwing wouldn't fit but man I
love him he should ring the doorbell at
the end and move on like what's
continuity
um how is he alive and how old is he and
has there been Robins uh but yeah this
was I mean it's gonna be hard to top
next movie whatever we watch uh but that
as we say that what do you want to see
us watch next leave it in the comments
below we try to check those comments out
you guys seem to be enjoying these but
make sure to share them make sure
because that's how we get to keep making
them is he's getting shared in those
views so share them out and uh hit the
like this is your responsibility dear
viewer but uh before we get out of here
let's give some love to a pig
all right so and we're gonna give a
patron of the day shout out to Lex
because it would have been weird if
Superman showed up and it would have
been even weirder if Lex Luthor showed
up for no reason this is a contained
universe but we know somewhere out there
in the Jeff lope himself at all Lex is
out there just like Lex is out there
keeping us going supporting being a a
silent Guardian like Batman is in this
white knight Dark Knight Saga uh selects
much appreciated for uh one you being a
patron to the Simplicity your name three
having a three letter name and something
I enjoy four not killing super mix we
appreciate them oh dude you know you
know my dear that one uh first and
foremost maybe the best reason you know
just that we love you yeah for not
killing students it's up there I mean
you've begrudgingly helped save the
world many many times many times we owe
it to you yeah at the very least minimal
at least we could do so being you know
being a billionaire being uh you know
problematic as billionaires are at least
don't kill Superman sweet we think thank
you for that don't do it don't do it
invest in in pharmaceutical companies
and make prescriptions lower like uh
Mark Cuban be that kind of billionaire
Lex make those moves we appreciate those
uh long Halloween was exceptional Lex
you're exceptional
everyone comment below like share
appreciate you go hug your family and
watch some good movies much love see you
soon peace foreign